I need a call.
I need to join Gumi's discord.
Creepy.
Alright, I'm in.
I need to wait for Gumi to get here.
Should I... Hello?
Hello?
Hello, Gumi?
What's up, stupid?
What's up, bitch?
Can you join my club?
I'm gonna create a club right now.
I made my own.
Oh.
Okay.
I made my own already.
What the fuck, Gumi?
Can I join your club?
Yeah.
What's your club called?
Guess.
Pick a guess.
Um... Spin my mouth?
I'm not gonna do that.
What the fuck?
Right?
What the... This is like...
Like Hunger Games, you know?
This trick.
I mean it's...
What the fuck is that?
What is that old key?
Ew.
Gross.
How do you loot this?
Wait, where's the loot?
Oh shit, there's so much loot in the middle.
Oh shit!
My loot now.
This map is so pretty.
Wait, is he fighting someone?
Fuck if I know.
I don't know what's going on.
Where are you, Gumi?
Where am I?
I'm heading towards the circle.
What the fuck are these people?
Are those my teammates?
I'm not gonna let you go.
So there's no enemies in this mode, is that what you're telling me?
Like who is this?
Hey.
Oh, I have teammates!
Wait, let me see.
Yeah!
I have teammates!
Like you'll see like teammate shadows and stuff.
Like you see the...
Yeah, see look.
This guy.
Hey.
He thinks he can shoot me.
His name is Chingu.
Aww.
That means run.
Oh!
It's preview.
Preview mode is to explore the map.
There's no fighting.
Buttholes, buttholes.
Get in the butthole.
I am.
What the fuck.
This is a long ass butthole.
Oh no, Chingu.
He's dead.
Chingu?
How is he dead?
He fell.
He fucking fell.
Oh my god.
Wait, is that a car?
Wait, that's a car!
That guy got a car.
Wait, are you fighting them?
He's popping off.
Are you actually?
They're right here.
Wait, watch this.
Just stand here my gas.
Stand here my gas.
I cracked him.
He's flush.
Hey, I'm one.
I'm kind of one.
He's one too.
He's leaving.
Alright.
He can't see me.
Oh!
He sees me!
Oh my god.
I can't see.
He's going.
You can climb up here, stupid!
Now I'm just in the open.
You can climb up.
You should have climbed up.
I got one.
Wait, Pathfinder's up.
Bloodhound's one.
I'm not standing.
Hey, I need help, Gumi.
This guy.
This one guy.
Just shoot him.
Don't let him...
I'm not standing.
He's cracked.
He doesn't have a gun.
You stupid...
Gumi, are you okay?
Are you okay, Gumi?
What do you mean, I'm okay?
Bye, Gumi.
No, no, no.
Watch this.
Thanks for the blue.
Donkey, come back here and gas me then heal me.
Why am I crawling so fast?
Donkey.
He can't shoot me.
Wait.
Wait a minute, guys.
Gumi, I think they're coming over.
Why do you guys have to shoot it though?
Because, oh my god, look at my...
Look at this monster right here.
Alright, get in here.
Get in here, boys.
Oh my god, look at this.
Look at this.
Wait, can I fit there?
Oh my god, what the fuck?
Wait, where are they?
Wait, oh no, I don't know where...
I think the gas cans are lagging the car.
Oh shit.
Wait.
Look at that.
I'm sorry.
I didn't know.
I thought I would make it.
I'm sorry.
Me.
Okay.
Um.
I don't think I should drive, guys.
I'm sorry.
It's a one by one car.
I have so much to cook.
I have some help here.
Yeah.
Where are they?
Where?
No, please.
Please.
What do you mean?
There's two?
Yes, I'm fucking...
Sento!
Please!
Hey, can someone shoot at this man that is shooting at me?
Okay.
I did and I missed every shot.
I just want you to know.
And I have this.
I did and I missed every shot.
I'm so sorry.
Who the fuck told me to play Caustic?
Who's wrong with you guys?
You.
Me too.
Wait, what the fuck?
Yo!
I can walk up top.
Hey, Kumi.
I'm taking your shit above you.
Please.
It's just an armor.
Don't worry.
Please.
All you have been doing is bringing me pain.
Pain and suffering.
And love.
You love me, right?
I love you.
Alright, who wants to get in?
Alright, guys.
Get in.
Get in, Kumi.
Please!
Kumi,
get in.
Oh, wait.
Kumi, get in.
Hey, Sento, get in.
See?
Sento trusted me.
She's gonna run me over.
I can't run you over like that.